y volver a casa en decenas de autobuses
afganos desplazados del conflicto
regresarán a sus lugares de origen
hace 12 meses que estamos desplazadas
pasamos un año bajo una tienda de
campaña y los aldeanos nos colocaron
dentro de una habitación ahora estamos
contentas de que nuestro gobierno nos
devuelva a nuestras provincias
hace dos o tres años que estoy
desplazado de laghman viviendo en una
casa alquilada recibí algunas ayudas de
diferentes fuentes ahora vamos a hacer
nuestra provincia
la agencia de la onu acnur que trabaja
en el complejo de refugiados de kabul en
sintonía con el ministerio local de
repatriación buscan que más de 200
familias regresen a sus provincias
hoy se trata de un movimiento de unas
230 familias es decir unas 1600 personas
que regresan pero en total esta semana
hemos tenido 5500 desplazados internos
que han salido de kabul hacia sus
hogares y provincias de todo el país son
personas que han estado desplazadas
algunas de ellas durante muchos años
debido al conflicto y que ahora se
sienten seguras para volver a casa
según acnur entre enero y julio de 2021
los desplazados internos en afganistán
llegaban a los 550.000 además de poner
en riesgo su vida por estar expuestos a
ataques de grupos armados deben
enfrentar los embates del clima como las
sequías o un futuro incierto en otros
países de la región a donde han huido de
la guerra